little seating is our little [ __ ] where
okay stop it
our mulatto
instead of asking you who started I
could also say coming up Omega literally
it means how does it go so it's general
it doesn't matter if enemies one person
or people to say George no no Jeannie
so what did I ask
the contest could be it could be a party
but in this case a celebration or a
holiday yeah Donna orbits day
oh yeah it's Wednesday hey stop
bravissimo
perfect perfecto Donna to end
Donna yes
so it's celebrated well everywhere
around the world it's the International
International Women's Day and it's a day
when we honor women and well we try to
remind ourselves that we need to make a
constant action to keep equality and to
be fair in every aspect of life so I
mean it's really funny because in the
u.s. everybody's paying attention to a
quality but there isn't a big
celebration for la Festa Bella Donna
while listen it's different since about
a 1945 we actually celebrate Women's Day
the conditions will be matter worse in
value than here
but we still celebrate the Festa de la
donna today you can vary Italy every
time you meet a woman you would say our
body literally means wishes but it's
like felicitations and you can use it in
every context it's not just for Women's
Day it's like it's your birthday our
body New Year's it's a woman Christmas
you graduate have a good fit and then
you can say specifically for this day
Juana
what does it mean yeah yes so literally
it would mean good celebration of the
woman but me she would say happy Women's
Day
okay so try to say look together one two
three at school we learned that the
origin of this day has the root in two
events that happened outside Italy on
the 8th of March 1 pattern on the 8th of
March 1857 and it was a strike of
garment workers in New York in the US
and well apparently after the strikes
but this tracks led to the formation of
the women noodle you news no I added a
little bit of research and according to
some historians this event never
happened so is it true
no no so so let's try this she said
Juanita seller today
meet dr. Trent you got a second
I told you that it was it's a shop you
need to know this word because I'm like
99% sure that there would be some sort
of Shambala
for example the shop where are they
today yes yeah or some other sort of
shopper so it's good if you know this
word so I told you that they were two
events that led to the choice of their
Optimax of the best vanilla don't know
this is the first event the second one
it's again it's another shopper oh this
one lock top hat so
this is a sector me let me know I
changed oh no it just
and that's shopper oh there was a
shopper up in Russia he said be careful
so women were protesting because well it
was a very hard period there was affect
the First World War and then there was
also the Russian Revolution going on so
the world about the deaths and there was
that food so they were making this show
better they'll impanel it in la pocha so
for bread yes
peace
yeah so immediately we celebrated in
many different ways but there are no
meetings discussions for discussions but
then it's also nice because there's
traditional gift a very simple gift that
people give to women in their lives and
this gift is a flower called mimosa it's
a yellow flower so it's a reminder that
it's Women's Day and also it's very nice
because it's going to be spring some
spring this is a step that the Talon
post office made in the occasion of the
test of Arizona last year and this is
the newest of flower it's nice it's
yellow and it has a very sweet smell
it's a tree
una better this tree is native to
Australia but we draw it in Italy
and particularly the latter of there are
lost of mimosa trees in Livadia
do you know and Olivia is so what I was
selling here is that we we draw a lot of
romanza India by the penetration you
would say indication it's a sort of
acacia it's kind of it
okay it's okay we're missing oh we have
our Islands yes and the mission I was
telling you about is called urea and
it's here
I've been talking a lot to now I thought
this particular now it's their turn
Joe gonna be yummy
Joe we cannot joy they do make you
stupid
IKEA IKEA very well the New Jersey mango
that Massachusetts because that's it yet
don't you give a second media teacher to
judge it because a judge ochio media j0t
piace CC we tha love these are good
answers if only some features so you
said I'm keone key option but instead
you should say okay MA yeah because the
subject is the pizza not you actually
it's a condom oh boy Oh genetic see ya
what did you like doing
oh we got to achieve Oh
that's food what did you do this weekend
I slept and did you oh did you say what
are you okay so yeah so sleep cook quick
Pete
this is great every time young would
understand but it was a mix of Spanish
and Italian
right everybody would understand so for
like I am sleeping still 30 men yes yes
so use the verb static becomes random if
I take
so today we are going to do chocolate
torte in usual I want you to try to talk
about typical day not typical the
typical day I never feel you use journo
yeah so was holding it so I didn't say
you don't know typical well in German
typical would be fine as well we used
word for example
yeah so literally fatso means yes I
chose shower but actually gotcha and we
use the verb for a fracture we use it in
a lot of different contexts well she
only goes did you go see only in place
at breakfast I have requested to let you
say no strata my teeth meet me laughs
identity
this is by
good how about in it
I heard or Fargo afar in a spacer so
washing machine and what we say we say
so you see you can use the word [ __ ] up
in English
you say friends it's alright
how do you decide the articles because
is so general rule said that protein is
a block but it takes time to remember
the rules so the best thing is practice
but in this case so see we are to be me
laura is amici it's masculine and it
starts with a vowel so for masculine
plural you have two options or since it
starts with last about plays a very
central rotation
everything revolves around food either
Mangiamo or Fujiyama or pavillion in
Montana there would be people who talk
about food what are the main meals we
already heard one
yes yes work and helicoid amici is amici
it may be both as students coloring fun
because
and finally if we take a typical fast of
a typical meal like in Prancer or
l'chaim actually we have typically a lot
of different courses when you see them
here first time I went to retell it with
my husband we were invited for dinner at
some friends house and so when we
started with antipasto then we had a
nice dish of pasta
so typically is pasta rice or soup it's
a condom it can be some mistake then we
know it's a side dish so soon our
classes I don't know if you noticed but
during the first four weeks we were just
cooking today Wow and then after four
weeks
and for weeks watching me on TV we can
make for better camera that would be
meatballs what but they know that every
time did you take something you mean sit
you put it together because you may add
some some breadcrumbs maybe one egg so
everything sticks together a little bit
of cheese you make some little balls
like meatballs
and then you either frightened or you
can make them or you can cook them with
low heat